tell me about your role within the royal
family
i was very very lucky um i spent 30
years
at buckingham palace as a royalty
protection officer i spent three years
looking after the queen's youngest son
prince edward and then i spammed i was
up at cambridge yes it was at cambridge
university that's where i first met
alistair okay
and then i spent 13 and a half years as
personal protection officer to his rohan
as the juke of edinburgh and then i was
lucky enough to spend the last 14 years
of my career
as the queen's personal protection
officer a position called the queen's
police officer until i retired her wit
and charm how did you find her
oh
i would give you 101 examples of a wit
and a charm and would you like some
yes please
oh yes please go for it
yeah
okay
well one of my favorite stories is when
we were at balmoral and the queen used
to go up there in may to krogan house
and just stay there privately for a
weekend
and she would go with lunchtime for
picnics and very often it would just be
the police officer and her majesty and
one of the picnics i went out with her
we had a lovely picnic and a lovely chat
and then we went for a little walk just
the two of us and normally on these
picnic sites you meet nobody but there
was two hikers coming towards us and the
queen would always stop and say hello
and it was two americans on a walking
holiday
and it was clear from the moment that we
first stopped they hadn't recognised the
queen which is fine
and the american gentleman was telling
the queen where he came from where they
were going to next
and where they'd been to in britain
and i could see it coming and sure
enough he said her majesty and where do
you live and she said well i live in
london but i've got a holiday home just
the other side of the hills
and he said well how often have you been
coming up here
oh she said i've been coming up here
ever since i was little girl so over 80
years
and you can see the clogs thinking he
said well if you've been coming at me
for 80 years you must have met the queen
and as quick as a flash says well i
haven't the [ __ ] meets her regularly
[Laughter]
so the guy said to me you've met the
queen what you like and because i was
with her a long time when i knew i could
pull a leg i said well she can be very
cantankerous at times
but she's got a lovely sense of humor
anyway the next thing i knew this guy
comes around put his arm around my
shoulder and before i could see what's
happening he gets his camera gives it to
the queen and says can you take a
picture of the two of us
anyway we swapped places and i took a
picture of them with a queen and we
never let on and we waved goodbye and in
a majesty said to me i'd love to be a
fly in the wall when he shows us
photographs to the friends in america
and hopefully someone tells him who i am
oh that's brilliant